- All right, thank you for coming.
So who here has intended
to build a Frankenstack?
None of us.
None of us say, you know
what sounds like fun?
Six databases, three
caches, a message bus,
two streaming platforms,
a homemade ETL pipeline
that runs only on full moons.
It just happens, like
when you forget about
that Halloween pumpkin
and it suddenly collapses
into an orange pile of goo on your porch.
So again, quick show of hands,
how many people here
maintain more than five
data stores right now?
And how many of you suspect
there are even more than that,
that have not been touched
since the year 2020?
All right, so you're in the right place.
This talk is really for all of us.
We're gonna explore how
Frankenstacks happen
and why AI agents make them worse,
and how to then, and how
we avoid ending our careers
managing something that
looks like it escaped
from a haunted data center.
So teams tell me the same
story over and over again.
The demo's easy.
Production, that's where the real work is.
And not just like a little
work, like a village of work,
with like guilds and
blacksmiths and stuff.
Complexity doesn't grow
linearly with systems
or even exponentially.
With data stores, it grows factorially
and nobody wants a system
that scales factorially.
It's like adopting a kitten
and waking up with a herd
of blood-hungry lions.
So let me ask you,
how many of you feel like
your system works great
until suddenly it falls apart?
That's, at the end of the
day, the Frankenstack effect.
And here's the twist.
AI agents are actually gonna amplify
this effect significantly.
So let's dive in.
So of course this is how it starts.
You have hope, you have ambition,
you have a clean architecture diagram.
In this case, we have an AI agent stack.
They're a web/mobile app, an OLTP system,
a vector data store.
It's good enough to win a hackathon.
It's good enough to get your
boss to give you an applause.
And it's good enough to
maybe even win a trophy,
at very least get yourself a free T-shirt.
We are in the honeymoon
phase at this point.
You've wowed the team, your POC works.
Maybe even you have a demo
video with some upbeat music.
Someone in the back
shouts from rags to riches
and you don't even groan at that dad joke
'cause you're so proud
of what you've made.
Your architecture feels extensible.
You need search?
No problem, bolt on another store.
Need recommendation engine?
Need analytics?
No problem, bolt on
yet another data store.
And of course this is the
point at which we all say,
we'll clean it up later,
but we all know the truth.
We've all built these systems before.
We're not cleaning anything up ever.
So a monster starts.
The complexity doesn't start very loudly,
doesn't start with a bang,
it starts with little whispers.
Grows at the seam with every
new data store, every sync job,
every environmental variable
someone adds just for the time being.
Frankenstacking is not one bad decision,
happens because of 50 reasonable ones.
And once the symptoms appear,
the creepy crawlies have
made home in your system
and the symptoms come out.
Latency, cache inconsistency,
schema drifts, surprise cost.
A debugging process that
takes three Slack channels,
a seance, and goat's blood sprinkled
three times over your left shoulder.
They're aren't big traumatic failures.
They're annoying, creepy crawly
ones like the little beetles
that get inside your pumpkin
and turn it into mush.
So let's move from the
theoretical to a customer story.
A high scale E-Commerce platform
running a pricing optimization engine.
Here's where all of these
little decisions have added up.
So we're gonna start with a
user who's clicking Buy Now on,
I don't know, maybe a
Frankenstein costume, let's say.
We wanna personalize a discount
based on their intent and live inventory.
Very normal, very normal.
At this moment, your
system springs into action.
It's gonna hit the inventory system,
your OLTP database, event
stream's gonna work,
all very classic patterns.
We're about to see like
a tiny spark hitting
those dry fall leaves when
an agent comes into play,
and the request fans out,
all the different systems
that we're going to touch.
And each of these different
systems is gonna operate
independently with its own
SLAs and its own quirks.
So the next step, our
agent springs in action.
It's gonna be in orchestrating by pulling
cache profiles from your key value store,
recent behavioral trend from
your time series database,
and blending that together
with the pricing engine.
Next we're gonna add search and discovery.
So agent's gonna queries your search DB
for similar products, queries
your vector DB for embeddings
and similarity matches, going
back to your product catalog
and your inventory levels,
pulling all of that.
And of course, we're hoping
that this returns in
under 50 milliseconds.
But of course, we're not even done yet.
There's more.
You wanna improve your models.
So you're adding in your lakehouse,
you're adding in your analytics
warehouse, reporting tables,
model training orchestration.
All of that data is now
exported, transformed,
reingested, versioned,
stitched back together
to be put into their online system.
Not only that, we essentially
have two parallel stacks.
One for our real-time
and one for our batch.
Our architecture is now
basically a giant spiderweb
of interdependencies.
In our POC, our life was simple.
We had maybe three systems, a web app,
OLTP database, a vector store.
Fast forward to production.
We now have a small village of systems.
So quick show of hands, how many of you
have an architecture diagram
more like the one on the left
than the one on the right?
It's okay, guys.
This is a safe space.
You can raise your hands.
I see some.
I see some pained smiles.
The one on the left, right?
So it's okay, this here
is your support group.
Instead of going with the
clean architecture diagram,
we have an architecture diagram
that looks like we've
disemboweled a martian,
put it on a slide and
said, yeah, sure, ship it.
It's perfect.
And the worst part here is those of us
with experience know that over time,
supporting the architecture
diagram on the left
is even worse than building it.
Right, because like.
Let's look at some zombie
pipelines over here
that should have died years ago.
We have a skeleton crew for support
that isn't even pictured here.
With the the real human
cost and a web of connection
that feels like the world's
saddest haunted house.
And the whole thing works
because you have an entire team
of people who are living
and breathing every day just
to keep this propped up.
So let's go ahead and
enumerate some of these costs.
Latency, which spikes unpredictably,
embeddings that drift,
caches that are stale,
and complexity that ramps up.
Suddenly everyone, instead of
getting a good recommendation,
is getting a recommendation
based on your interest in clown shoes.
You fix one problem
and there's more problems
decomposing over in the corner.
In a week or two, you know
you're gonna have a whole field
of rotting pumpkins.
But don't worry,
you know that you have
a new project upcoming,
a new job offer.
And we're gonna get over to that new one
before anyone notices that
field of rotting pumpkins.
And of course the hiring burden
for this, just keep it up.
We haven't even talked about that.
'Cause you need experts in each
of these different data stores
in order to operate them.
Our agents aren't dashboards
at the end of the day.
They aren't batch jobs, they're
interactive stateful systems
that need real-time access
to structured, unstructured,
vector and event data.
If even one of these pieces is slow,
the entire system collapses faster
than a rotting pumpkin on December 4th.
So let's flip the problem around,
and let's start from the agent's needs
instead of the systems
that we've inherited.
Things are about to get simpler.
First, agent needs one system
that reads their enterprise data
and runs common functions like vector,
nearest neighbors, with
minimal data movement
and ultimately minimal overhead.
Needs faster development
patterns, fewer lines of code,
fewer dependencies to babysit.
Ultimately that's also
fewer tokens going in
and out of the models
that are building them.
Every external system you remove
is one less SDK to upgrade.
One less client library
to patch and one less,
why is this suddenly failing
in production message
that you're getting at Slack at 2:00 AM.
Of course, agents need
fewer processes to monitor.
Every background job, every sync task,
every streaming consumer you
bolt on becomes one more ghost
haunting your on-call rotation.
We want fewer demons involved.
And of course that's both the
technical and Halloween sense.
So when you start with the agent's needs,
architecture looks less
like a haunted house.
It starts looking like something
you can actually support
on Monday mornings.
So our customers won't let us play
with their production code,
but I can recreate something,
recreated a demo of
what it is they did
just to get some metrics
behind the Frankenstack effect.
Huge differences.
These are measurable differences.
Measurable cost, measurable
differences in velocities.
Just look at lines of code,
3x difference between single store
versus a bolted on system.
Database connections.
With each database connection,
again, that's more maintenance
that has to be done.
One versus two.
Failure points, only one
to manage instead of three.
Just, you can, with
each different addition
of databases, data stores,
that's more room for gremlins
to hide in your stack.
So let's talk about the part
every engineer in this room feels,
why a single database
makes production feel sane.
With everything living in one place,
your production stops
being a haunted house,
maze of pipelines, caches of sync jobs.
And why is this table only updated
at three-quarter moon cycles?
Your debugging is predictable.
CI/CD much easier with one system.
On-call is quieter, significantly quieter.
Many fewer people involved,
much faster incident resolution.
Not to mention scaling.
Scaling gets easier as well
with one system to scale up.
One system that's billing,
one graph to watch,
one team of experts who
can do all the hard work
to debug your one system.
So we've gone from a house
full of spooky corners,
dangling cables, forgotten cron jobs,
to a clean, predictable, well-lit system
that your agents can use
and your teams trust.
All right, so let's go ahead
and we'll bring this home now.
When your team moves from a Frankenstack
to a unified database,
the very first thing you
will notice is speed.
Not theoretical speed, but human speed,
team speed, feature speed.
Because everything is now
working on a single data store.
You can ship updates without having
those three team meetings
or that one meeting
that really should just be an email.
Product managers like me can
get features out in just weeks
rather than months of wrangling all
of the different engineering
teams to get it done.
Nobody has to maintain that
one mysterious ETL job.
We know that ETL job,
the one that only runs on full moons
the day after February 29th.
So here's the big message that I want
to leave everybody here with.
Your Frankenstack doesn't happen
because of a bad decision.
It happens because our architectures
are built for dashboards,
and now we're asking them
to power real-time multimodal AI agents.
AI agents that need real-time state,
they need low latency access,
they need consistent vector,
structured and unstructured
data and no surprises.
So I want to go ahead and
thank you all for joining us.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for putting up with
all of my bad Halloween jokes
and I hope you have a great
rest of your re:Invent.
By the way, if you wanna
learn more about single store,
we are at Booth 1559
or ask the guys in the back
over there with their hands up.
Thank you all very, very much.
Have a great re:Invent.
(audience cheering and clapping)